rescuers at a flooded cave in Thailand
are desperately looking for ways to free
a youth soccer team that is trapped
inside before more heavy rain arrives
twelve boys and a coach have been stuck
in the cave for nearly two weeks up to
five inches of rain are expected in the
region over the next 10 days some areas
will get up to 9 inches Ben Tracy is
outside the cave in Chiang Rai Thailand
Ben good morning good morning so
rescuers have been looking for an
entrance to this cave from above hoping
that perhaps they could airlift the boys
out they are worried about the heavy
rains that are headed this way this
weekend but they may flood the cave
again and make any sort of rescue
attempt nearly impossible emergency
workers are racing to pump out the
excess water from the flooded cave
trying to bring the levels down so it's
safer to attempt to rescue the boys
they're drilling through rocks to make
room for hoses which have already helped
remove more than 31 million gallons of
water doctors are treating and feeding
the young soccer players who are being
given a crash course in swimming and how
to wear dive masks in case they have to
make the dangerous attempt to swim out
of the dark and narrow cavern be
terrifying but the children who are
aware of the cave I know the caves I've
been in the cave very often so we just
have to assess everything at the moment
several sections of the cave remain
flooded including an area that requires
full diving equipment rescue workers
hope they can drain enough water to
eliminate long stretches where the boys
would have to keep their heads under
water Tana watts is the father of the
youngest boy trapped in the cave an 11
year old known as Titan are you worried
about how they're going to try to get
them out of the cave he'll be punchy he
says I believe the SEAL team can make it
happen there is nothing they can't do I
have faith Tana watt says that Thai Navy
SEALs have not told the families when or
if they will attempt the dangerous
rescue and he knows it may be safer for
his son to stay in the cave until the
water recedes once your son finally
comes home what's the first thing you're
going to say to him
I will tell him you are home and you are
safe me and your mother were waiting for
you and we love you now I did ask Titans
father if he blames the 25 year old
soccer coach who apparently went into
the cave with these boys
despite the signs of risk and he says he
does not he says he's a good guy and he
gave all of his food and water to the
boys into the rescuers arrived M&E Ben
Tracy and Thailand thanks he has so many
questions still about those boys could
be down there for a long time we are
rooting for them yes we all are rooting
for those boys